70% of the silent movies made in America have
been lost.
The average human body contains 0.2mg of gold.
Until the 1940s, fake snow in movies was made
by painting cornfakes white.
If you drink one glass of water for every
alcoholic beverage, it significantly reduces
your chance of getting a hangover.
Usain Bolt ate 1,000 chicken nuggets during
the Beijing Olympics because he didn't like
Chinese food.
Sheep can see behind themselves without moving
their heads.
There are more libraries in Britain's prisons
than there are in its schools.
If you hold your breath and put your face
in cold water, your heart will immediately
slow down by 25%.
A person usually makes a lot of hand gestures
when telling the truth.
When telling a lie however, a person's hands
tend to stay still.
1 in 5 kidneys donated in the US are thrown
away because a suitable recipient can't be
found.
People spend 47% of their waking hours thinking
about something other than what they're doing.
Anthropologists believe that man has known
how to use fire for 500,000 years, but only
learned how to make it himself 12,000 years
ago.
A peppier is a waiter whose sole job is to
go round with a pepper grinder.
A “moment” is actually a medieval unit
of time that means 90 seconds.
At Stalin's funeral 500 people were trampled
to death.
The force required to pull one leg from quicksand
is the same needed to lift a small car.